president biden brought together a
divided nation last night with a rousing
clear message
we're at a great inflection point in
history
we have to do more than just build back
better we build back we have to build
back
better we need to do more than build
back better we need to build back build
back build
build back better the president gave
an arbitrary state of the union address
last night to a mostly
empty chamber filled with people who
were
muzzled inside a capital that was
totally
fenced off in a city under military
occupation
thank goodness we put down that
insurrection a few months ago
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
have to say it sure did have some
insurrectiony kind of vibes last night
though most people didn't notice that
because most people couldn't stay awake
my favorite comment
from yesterday is from kb who said hey
michael
did youtube make you guys take out that
joe rogan vaccine segment yesterday
funny you should ask that i just learned
that apparently that was the case you
know last week on my
show i read for i did a little
experiment
i read from a peer-reviewed scientific
study that was published on the national
institutes of health
that contradicted the prevailing
narrative that masks are really really
good and healthy
and helpful at stopping the virus i
i just i didn't have any commentary i
just read
from the peer-reviewed scientific study
published on the very national
institutes of health
that are supposed to be running our
public health apparatus
and this youtube was very upset about
that because they don't want us to
follow the science
so then i played this clip from joe
rogan yesterday
where joe rogan took aspects of that
sort of study to
their logical conclusion and youtube
they did not like that
they didn't like that so we've got to be
very very careful here we don't want to
cite any scientific studies
because the liberal establishment and
its enforcement wing in youtube they're
not going to like that because it might
contradict the assault to dr fouchy
peace be upon him so you'll have to go
to dailywire.com
or listen to the audio podcast if you
want to hear peer-reviewed scientific
studies because
youtube it doesn't want that because
we've got to follow the scion
just the scientists we gotta just we
gotta follow fouchy we gotta just do
whatever fauci says even if that is in
contravention of
the science gosh the internet making
things
pretty complicated for us here isn't it
seems like things were simpler in the
past
there's one area though where the
internet has made things much much
easier and that would be in the process
of
purchasing auto parts when you want to
get any part for your car truck head on
over to
rockauto.com rockauto.com is
so much easier than walking into a store
and someone demanding quick answers to
things like hey
michael is your honda an lx or an ex
i don't how am i supposed to know that
you go you go look you go look at my car
and then i don't know
they go they say oh yeah you need this
part but we don't have the parts and
they go in the back what do they do they
go online probably to rockholder.com
they order the part
it costs twice as much skip skip that
humiliation
skip that degradation go to rockauto.com
you can do it from your desk you can do
it
from your pocket just on your phone
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
price as possible
rather than saying okay it's going to be
10 more this day and 30
now it's just always reliably low prices
the same for pros such as myself
and do-it-yourselfers such as you head
on over to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck
then write null scanner w-l-e-s in there
how did you hear about us box
so that they know we sent you if you
stayed awake for the state of the union
address last night that
is more than you can say for most people
even even ted cruz there was a great
clip of him
in the audience because there were it
wasn't a joint session it was just
some scattered number of people there
and cruz was
sort of paying attention but then his
eyes would droop a little and wake him
up again
and this is very much in keeping with
what ted cruz has said
about the biden administration which is
that
it's boring but radical so it's a lot of
the same old platitudes
but then a lot of really radical far
left policies that they're pursuing
it was tired old talking points from a
tired old man last night in the biden
address
joe biden if you closed your eyes which
most people were doing
you could have thought that you were
hearing a democrat address from i don't
know
the mid-2000s or you know 2012 or
something from
from years ago he he focused on that
that old canard about the one percent
and how the rich need to pay their fair
share
i will not impose any tax increase on
people making less
than four hundred thousand dollars it's
but it's time for corporate america and
the wealthiest one percent of americans
have just begun to pay their fair share
just their fair share sometimes i have
arguments with my
friends in the democratic party i think
you should be able to become a
billionaire and a millionaire
but pay your fair share a recent study
shows
that 55 of the nation's biggest
corporations
paid zero federal tax last year
okay joe and and who did those
corporations donate to
who did those millionaires vote for the
bait that joe biden wants you to take
is this idea that the democratic party
is the party of poor people
and the working class and the
republicans they're the party of the
oligarchs and the millionaires and the
billionaires it's just not true
millionaires voted for joe biden the big
corporations in america
disproportionately
gave and vote gave two and voted for joe
biden wall street who'd they give to
mostly
biden and associated democrats so
f on the one hand i think great tax him
as h.l menken says democracy is the
theory that the common people know what
they want and deserve to get it good and
hard i guess in this case
in our very corrupted democracy it's the
theory that these entrenched special
interests
and millionaires and billionaires know
what they want deserve to get it good
and hard fine give it to them
on the other hand as long as we're
citing studies
we should point out that the rich pay
virtually all of the taxes in the
country i went through all of the
numbers on this
in a recent speech i gave for the young
americas foundation so this
this rhetoric is purely the rhetoric of
envy it's not the even the rhetoric
of greed it's not it's not even the
rhetoric of i
want something it's more than ready to
recover i don't want someone else to
have it
you know the wealthy defined as we
ordinarily define it paid something like
what 97
of personal income taxes so what do they
want they want them to pay 98
99 no they just it's just more they just
want them to pay more
but in this case because the rhetoric is
so outdated
joe biden is not even willing to
acknowledge that the rich
vote for democrats so fine you want to
tax the rich okay
fine by me joe it's probably not not
going to work out
very well then he moves on to the race
baiting
we knew that the race-baiting was going
to happen they've been doing this not
just for two years they've been doing
this for
many many decades here joe biden says
that
the greatest scourge in this country
white supremacy
the threat has evolved way beyond
afghanistan
those you're in the intelligence
committees the foreign relations
committee defense committees
you know well we have to remain vigilant
against the threats of the united states
wherever they come from
al qaeda and isis are in yemen syria
somalia
other places in africa in the middle
east and beyond
and we won't ignore what our
intelligence agencies have
determined to be the most lethal
terrorist threat to the homeland today
white supremacy is terrorism we're not
going to ignore that either
my fellow americans look we have to come
together
to heal the soul of this nation we have
to come together
white supremacy is is a terrible awful
prominent scourge and trump supporters
they're all racist and white
supremacists
we have to come together we have to
trust the intelligence
agencies oh the intelligence agencies
who spied on behalf of
barack obama on the trump campaign the
intelligence agencies who
cooked up with the democrats a
completely
bogus russia dossier on president trump
the intelligence agencies who colluded
with democrats
to try to overthrow the trump
administration for four years
i guess eventually it worked out for
them those intellect yeah we got to
trust the intelligence agencies
okay buddy and what are the intelligence
agencies just
i just out of curiosity what are they
telling us oh that the great threat is
white supremacy
white supremacy because of what
because some skinheads posted some memes
or something once because there have
been
i don't know a handful i guess of white
supremacist
attacks in recent decades
blm burns the country down last year and
threatens to burn the country down again
that no no that's not a threat that's
not that's actually that's wonderful
that's healing
when you loot the nike store and you
burn down minneapolis
and washington dc and other cities all
around the country
that is healing and that's good and
that's peaceful mostly peaceful at least
but if you post some edgy memes
that's the real that's the real threat
folks
uh it doesn't seem very convincing to me
and then and then
when when he's checked off those boxes
the old stale talking points
and the typical race hustling then joe
biden does something
that is at at least tactically probably
a little smarter
he tries to take credit for trump
policies so
so probably the most popular thing he
said all night you got to give him
credit
is joe biden said we've been in
afghanistan too long and we've got to
bring the troops home
the war in afghanistan as we remember
the debates here
were never meant to be
multi-generational undertakings
of nation building we went to
afghanistan to get
terrorists the terrorists attacked us on
9 11.
and we said we would follow osama bin
laden to the gates of hell
to do it if you've been in the upper
conar valley you've kind of seen the
gates of hell
and we delivered justice to bin laden we
degraded the terrorist threat
of al-qaeda in afghanistan and after 20
years of value
valor and sacrifice it's time to bring
those troops home
very popular line president trump
actually
ran his campaign largely on the idea
that we had had a bunch of failed
foreign wars in the middle east
and that we should bring the troops home
then i i remembered when i was thinking
oh this is joe biden that's okay he's
adopting this trump policy that's sort
of interesting
i said wait a second why why are we
still in afghanistan
a lot of people don't remember this but
by 2007 or so
afghanistan was kind of over that war
was kind of done
and in 2007 barack obama
obama biden that was the ticket going
into 2008
campaigned on restarting the afghanistan
war
because barack obama was campaigning
against the iraq war
and as he was campaigning to pull the
troops out of iraq he needed a good war
right if iraq was the bad war he needed
a good war to fight he said we put too
much energy in iraq we didn't put enough
energy in afghanistan
so then he surged the troops in
afghanistan
the current iteration of the afghanistan
war was a creation of barack obama
donald trump ran to pull that down and
now joe biden
half of the obama biden administration
half of the obama biden ticket
is running against the policy that he
himself championed and restarted
in afghanistan fine better late than
never i guess
a a really painful state of the union
address i know a lot of conservatives
don't like the state of the union ben
talked about this last night because he
said it's it's
quasi-monarchical it's against the
american
real against the libertarian sort of
understanding of things okay
it doesn't really bug me i think there's
always going to be some spiritedness
in the executive branch i think that's
the purpose of the executive branch
is to is to convey the the thumas
the spirited part of the government just
like the
legislature expresses the repetitive or
emotional part and the judiciary
expresses the rational part it's
supposed to be an analog of the
tripartite soul
and in in practice i guess in practice
it works like a lot of our souls in that
it's corrupted and
sort of broken but okay i get it i
understand why
we do that but in recent years really
starting with ronald reagan and then
going into overdrive
with bill clinton the speeches have
gotten really long they've gotten really
windy they've gotten unbearable
antonin scalia famously stopped going he
just thought it was a complete waste of
his time
last night it was the worst one it was
the worst one i've ever seen in my whole
life and i've been watching this since i
was a little kid
and yet the worst job on state of the
union night
and you know this joint address was sort
of the state of the union
the worst job is not even sitting in the
room or giving the speech
it's giving the rebuttal from the party
that is out of power
not a great job not a job that anybody
wants now
if you do want a great job and you want
to find people that are right for the
job you should check out zip recruiter
if you are a business owner who is
hiring you've got a lot of challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role because you know
that your people are going to be
your most important investment and it is
so hard to find
good help these days hiring can feel
like trying to find a needle in a
haystack
so what do people usually do they post a
job to some job board
and then they just hope they say i hope
someone sees it it's like throwing
spaghetti at the wall i'm mixing my
metaphors here you get the point
when you try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com knowles
they will go out they will actively find
those candidates
for you with ziprecruiter this notice
gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with one click then their
matching technology finds the people
with the right skills and experience for
your job
and actively invites them to apply
while other companies overwhelm you with
way too many options ziprecruiter finds
exactly what you're looking for that
needle in the haystack and you can try
it right now for free
at ziprecruiter.com knowles that is
zipruter.com
k-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
last night tim scott republican senator
from south carolina drew the short straw
and he had to give the rebuttal to joe
biden's fake state of the union address
ha what do i say about this it was
better than many
state of the union rebuttals i guess
sort of damning with faint praise here
it just just didn't do it it wasn't
quite there
in in some ways i think that the state
of the union
the rebuttal which many people view is a
great way to introduce yourself to the
nation
maybe kick off a presidential campaign
national ambitions
in some ways it is the guaranteed way to
doom
anyone's presidential ambitions they
never go well remember bobby jindal
remember president bobby jindal no
no nobody does he was governor of
governor of louisiana
he was picked to give the rebuttal he
gave a very bad rebuttal that was the
end of his campaign
marco rubio did relatively a better job
than most
and he gave the rebuttal and he had that
awkward moment where he was drinking
water out of a water bottle and it
didn't anyway
we we have not yet seen the rubio
administration and tim scott
same thing it was pretty weak stuff i
felt it it
tried to go in the right direction and
then he kind of jumbled it so i'll give
you a good example of this
tim scott called out the democrats for
one of the most visibly
difficult aspects of their policy this
year namely that they've locked kids
out of school out of their education and
locked them
up at home for a whole year tim scott
calls them out
locking vulnerable kids out of the
classroom
is locking adults out of their future
our public schools should have reopened
months ago
other countries did private and
religious schools did
science has shown for months that
schools are safe
but too often powerful grown-ups set
science aside
and kids like me were left behind
so you s this is the perfect tim scott
oration
in that you can see it's kind of going
in the right direction but it just kind
of misses it
so yes it was cruel and ridiculous of
democrats to lock kids out of school
specifically at a public school because
home schools obviously were operating in
private
many private schools were still open but
republicans always say that public
schools are terrible they're not serving
students
and worse they're they're indoctrinating
them in this wok
poisonous ideology that's making them
hate their country and not know anything
about
history or literature or anything else
for that matter so are we now
are republicans now the pro-public
school party
we're the ones who say it's it's really
important for children to be in public
school i thought we were saying that
public schools were harming children so
now we're saying
that not being in public school is
harming children it's just a jumbled
message
when tim scott says the science has
shown for months that we can send our
kids back to school
it's true there's no scientific evidence
that being in school would be harmful to
kids
but for the last year and a half i
thought republicans were making the
argument that we shouldn't
have a policy just based on the whims of
scientists
i i thought what we're saying is that
our politics should be based on
more than just the scientific data it
should be based on ethical
considerations it should be based on
our tradition it should be based on our
constitutional rights so
yeah we're scoring the the cheap point
on how the science is in our favor but
we're giving them the broader premise
that the science should dictate our
politics when it certainly should not
that's the idea of the progressive
leftists that is not the idea of
constitutional conservatives just kind
of
jumbled then tim scott comes out and
on the bright side he attacks critical
race theory
today cues are being taught that the
color of their skin
defines them again and if they look a
certain way
they're an oppressor from colleges to
corporations to our culture
people are making money and gaining
power by pretending we haven't made
any progress at all by doubling down on
the divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
it's backwards to fight discrimination
with different types of discrimination
and it's wrong to try to use our painful
past
to dishonestly shut down debates in the
present
okay good america's not a racist country
great really powerful message from the
guy giving the rebuttal to the state of
the union because what joe biden is
saying is america is a racist country
so tim scott giving the stands and
especially because joe biden's an old
white guy and tim scott is a young black
guy
so it's he's even got more credibility
here to say america is not a racist
nation that's good
but notice what's creeping in here words
like
progress we've made progress what is
that will we've certainly
in some in some ways the situation has
improved in the country
in some ways it has fallen apart
right there's no question about in some
ways we've
made progress especially on matters of
race but in some ways we've actually
gone backwards on matters of race right
now i think race relations are much more
tense than they were
in the early 2000s for instance so over
the last 20 years i think race relations
have degraded
but even this language of forward and
backward and progress and regress
does that not grant a kind of
progressive view of history
when he talks about the painful past
this is a little bit of a tricky
rhetorical tool for conservatives
because what conservatives want to do is
bring out and maintain and conserve the
best of the past
and then use what is best in the past
and what is
what is good and true and beautiful to
create a better politics than the one we
have right now
well if if the past is very painful why
would you want to look to the past
for any sort of wisdom and then tim
scott takes this to the logical
conclusion
when he invokes one of my least favorite
slogans to refer to slavery in
the united states he refers to the
original sin
black hispanic white and asian
republican
and democrat brave police officers in
black neighborhoods
we are not adversaries we are family
we are all in this together and we get
to live
in the greatest country on earth
the country where my grandfather in his
94 years
saw his family go from cotton
to congress in one lifetime
so i am more than hopeful
i am confident that our finest hour
is yet to come original sin
is never the end of the story not in our
souls
and not for our nation the real story is
always
redemption oh gosh this is
so close to being compelling but
actually it seems very damaging
so tim scott has this line he uses a lot
he says i we went from cotton to
congress in one generation
that's a very powerful story tim scott's
family is very very impressed tim scott
himself is very very impressive
the line just reads like a kind of
i don't know dated political rhetorical
tool
something that was what was so
refreshing about trump is he seemed like
a regular guy
it's funny because trump is probably the
least regular guy that we've had in
office since
i don't know washington roosevelt who
knows
but he talked like a regular guy and he
didn't
whereas when tim scott uses that phrase
or or uses the address to
describe his biography it just seems
like the sort of thing written by a
consultant like use that line and
use it in this way that is very
meaningful and persuasive and
heartwarming and it just it doesn't
really achieve any of those sorts of
things
but then he he refers to original sin he
doesn't say directly
that he's referring to slavery but i
think it's pretty obvious in the context
of cotton to congress
he's referring to a line that's very
common in american politics which is
that slavery is america's original sin
and the problem with that is that
slavery is not america's original sin
original sin is america's original sin
slavery is not unique to america the the
abolition of slavery is in some ways
is unique to the west slavery still
exists
outside of the west and in the west it
really does not
it's not unique to america within the
west either certainly not within the
rest of the world
but the idea that slavery is america's
original sin
is a is a really bad idea for our
politics
because it suggests that we can correct
our original sin we ourselves through
our own efforts alone
and that is not true when tim scott says
that the end of the story is redemption
it's not the sin the sin is not the end
of the story redemption is the end of
the story
that's true that's that is the heart of
christianity
but but not if the original sin
is this one political institution called
slavery
and if the redemption is through
ourselves and through our politics or
even through say i don't know
abraham lincoln or through the ongoing
progressive work to undo that original
sin
that's the opposite of the message of
christianity with the message of
christianity is that
we've we have fallen into sin all of us
are are complicit in this original sin
and
therefore we have this broken
nature this this sin and death pervade
the world but that god through his
infinite grace comes down and redeems us
and we are therefore
grateful for that and we haven't really
earned our redemption
but we now are are born a new born again
that's great
the the message of slavery america's
original sin and we're going to redeem
ourselves
that is a totally progressive view
of the situation and i i don't think tim
scott intended that i think he's trying
to give a christian message here
but it it ends up i think giving the
left
so much past bad future good we're going
to do it through the great work of
progressives
in fact progressives are going to set us
back
if anything to use that same kind of
language ben is going to be talking
about
biden's coma inducing radicalism today
so go make sure you check in
on ben's show also we got another high
energy episode of candace coming to you
tomorrow
uh coming to you friday rather what day
is it is today wednesday
thursday no it is tomorrow okay good
it'll be coming to you tomorrow it's
very hard i
i felt that i was comatose for about
three weeks during biden's address
candace is going to be talking to dave
rubin he's going to be talking about
governor nussolini out there in his
state of california he's going to be
talking about
the new republican standard bearer there
caitlyn jenner
subscribe now stream candace live on
fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
only on
daily wire and get 25 off a new
membership with code candace
at dailywire.com subscribe we'll be
right back with a lot more
tim scott's rebuttal to the state of the
the to the fake state of the union
mostly fell flat and in senator scott's
defense they all fall flat so he's he's
in good company
nevertheless cnn hated tim scott's
speech they were live
fact-checking him during the speech one
of the fact
checks though and this was a pretty big
problem for cnn although the viewers i'm
sure didn't notice it
is that tim scott got got it right
and cnn's fact checker got the fact
wrong specifically
with regard to president trump's
operation warp speed
what also struck me was that this was
not a message that was a donald trump
message
at all he was not speaking to the base
of the party except in one area
where he was refusing to give joe biden
any credit
on covet 19. he said the tide had
already turned
on covet 19 when
when biden became president and of
course everybody understands that
operation warp speed happened under
joe biden but getting vaccines into arms
was uh abiding operation hold on so
operation warp speed that was the
coronavirus
response team that happened under joe
biden what are you talking about
operation warp speed was a trump
initiative
they got the vaccine within two days of
the election
remember the election happens there was
this very convenient timing for the
liberal establishment where they didn't
announce the vaccine until a couple of
days after the election but nevertheless
donald trump's still president then he
was still president until january 20th
what on earth are you talking about it
was so we got to give biden credit for
operation warp speed but
joe biden had nothing to do with
operation warp speed so they caught this
a little bit later and this lady on cnn
did
try to sort of kind of correct what she
said
let me state i misstated it earlier
donald trump
uh gets credit for operation warp speed
uh but joe biden gets credit on getting
those vaccines those shots into your
arms
okay so sure yeah you're right
trump did the operation warp speed but
but still biden gets all the credit for
the vaccines
no he doesn't he doesn't get any credit
for it he he just
took the trump administration's plan
that had already been implemented very
well and he followed it out
and he he followed it out so to the t
that
all of the dates that donald trump gave
on when these things would happen
turned out to be true so you'll maybe
you won't remember this because the
mainstream media have done such a good
job
of memory holding this but president
trump for months said
we're going to get a vaccine by the end
of the year we're going to get shots in
people's arms by
april but most of america is going to be
able to get this vaccine
by april of next year all of the experts
and all of the democrats
told him that this was not possible and
that this was a lie and donald trump
stuck to his guns he said i'm telling
you
this is what's going to happen we'll
have manufactured at least
100 million vaccine doses before the end
of the year
and likely much more than that hundreds
of millions of doses will be available
every month and we
expect to have enough vaccines for every
american by april
and again i'll say that even at that
later stage the delivery will go
as fast as it comes they can deliver
they're very good
best i think probably the best in the
world president trump
you have repeatedly either contradicted
or been at odds with some of your
government's own top scientists the week
before last
the head of the centers for disease
control dr redfield said it would be
summer before the vaccine would become
generally available
to the public you said that he was
confused
and mistaken those are your two words
but
dr slowy the head of your operation worf
speed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives and there there's biden laughing
oh he's not going to get the vaccine
you should watch the whole we don't have
time to go through the whole clip today
chris wallace doesn't let up he and
trump back and forth and back and forth
you're saying your government's wrong
you're oh my gosh you're saying you're
going to get a vaccine that soon and
then it'll be distributed that's
all the experts say it's not going to
happen trump's saying it is going to
happen this is obviously just a
political game
that you all are playing that eucharist
wallace and you joe biden and you
the experts and you the you're all just
playing this stupid game
guess who was right guess who's right
you have
chris wallace and joe biden and the
experts and the companies and
everybody in the whole liberal
establishment on one side and all those
really smart people in the lab coats
and you have donald freaking trump
as if alone in the world on the other
side guess who was right
about the whole thing about when you get
the vaccine about when americans will
have access to the vaccine
trump was right and the rest of them
were wrong
which raises a question who should we be
trusting
on these issues of public health public
health the most of the great the
our true government the public health
who should we be trusting the experts
or people who have a little bit of
common sense
i got in trouble i got in trouble
yesterday you probably saw the episode
it was taken down on youtube the
segments taken down because i
played a clip of joe rogan and joe rogan
in that clip
discouraged young people from getting
the vaccine because he said look you're
quite healthy and so you just some
people
are at a far greater risk from covid and
you're not really
at nearly as great a risk so you know if
i were a young person i wouldn't get it
doc de fauci our great exalted leader
was asked about this joe rogan clip on
the today show he said
absolutely not joe rogan totally wrong
don't listen to him
everyone get the vaccine immediately
young healthy people shouldn't get
vaccinated just quickly your response
well that's incorrect savannah and the
reason why is that you're talking about
yourself in a vacuum
then you're worried about yourself
getting infected in likelihood that
you're not going to get any symptoms
but you can get infected and will get
infected if you put yourself at risk
and even if you don't have any symptoms
you're propagating the outbreak because
it is likely that you
even if you have no symptoms that you
may inadvertently and innocently
then infect someone else who might
infect someone
who really could have a problem with a
severe outcome
so if you want to only worry about
yourself and not society
then that's okay but if you're saying to
yourself even if i get infected
i could do damage to somebody else even
if i have no symptoms at all
and that's the reason why you've got to
be careful and get vaccinated yes
so if if you only care about yourself
you disgusting selfish peasant
then fine maybe you don't get the
vaccine i mean i'm still gonna make you
but if you're a good person then you
should get the vaccine
go jump in a lake this guy the vaccine
super duper effective right
vaccines and vaccine available basically
to every single person in the country
right now
so other than children because it's not
it's not approved for children yet
even though it's totally so it's great
it's awesome there's no question about
it whatsoever
but still not but it's approved for
everybody else other than children
so everyone can get the vaccine just
about uh but you
still need to get the vaccine because
otherwise even if you're not at risk
really
from the virus if you you could carry
the virus and be asymptomatic and you
could give it to other people
who are already by the way immune
because the vaccine works totally great
so they don't really need to worry about
getting it but you could have to worry
about giving it to the people who don't
have to worry about getting it is that
is that the argument get the vaccine
sheep
wear the mask sheep so i'm i'm not going
to make
any scientific point on on the vaccine
i'm not going to make any scientific
point on the masks i'm not going to make
any scientific argument on the whole
virus because i'm not allowed to
youtube won't allow me you see the the
liberal establishment acting through
youtube
is so confident of its argument that it
will not permit me to read a
peer-reviewed scientific study
from the national institutes of health
that's how confident they are
that they are speaking for the science
that's how confident they and
their arguments so i'm not going to do
that if you want to hear me read the
peer-reviewed scientific
study about the masks contradicting all
of the
wonderful proclamations of our public
health overlords go to dailywire.com
because you'll be able to check it out
over there
i would strongly recommend you do that
but i'm not going to do it because you
know if we go on youtube we're not
allowed to say that
i'm just going to make the purely
political
argument
i think the masks are dumb i'm not
saying that from a scientific standpoint
i'm not saying they don't work
not right now i'm not saying that i'm
saying as a political matter
it is disordered this is a disordered
thing for society
to wear the secular kefia over your face
it is a disordered thing for society to
continue to go around
muzzling yourself not seeing people
smile not going out
being able to breathe fresh air and see
the expressions on our faces
man is the political animal in
aristotle's term
why because we have speech because we
communicate with one another because
we're social
that is the defining political quality
of man
it's what separates us from the animals
and these idiots
these power mad
idiots are stopping us from doing that
and we are following along
it's not it's not just do this for a
while then do this then do this and
follow
they never give up the old measures that
they put in place
savannah guthrie this poor woman bless
her soul bless her heart
she's on nbc and she says you know dr
fauci
i mean i've been wearing the mask you
know i've been putting the mask of my
kids
and i just i don't let the kids outside
really when
can we allow kids to go outside and play
around
without the mask on their face you know
it sets up a strange
situation especially when you start
talking about kids i'll tell you a story
i walked to pick up my little girl at
the bus stop yesterday
after the cdc recommendations came out i
took off my mask
i waited for her there was no one else
around she got off the bus with her
little mask on
she had to wear her mask i didn't on the
walk home
when are kids going to be able to take
off those masks and play outside at the
playground
you know that's going to be the same
thing that i mentioned a moment ago it's
going to be a situation
well first of all kids will ultimately
wind up getting vaccinated but you want
to have some
activity in that direction before they
do
high school kids will likely get
vaccinated as we get into the fall term
and children of any age will likely be
vaccinated by the time we get to the end
of the year but let's not
talk about the end of the year let's
talk about the immediate or intermediate
future kids will get vaccinated okay
whenever i tell them to that's when
they'll get vaccinated and you sheep are
gonna do whatever i want you to do
my little newborn baby ain't getting
vaccinated okay
not not because i'm questioning the
vaccine and the efficacy
because he's a little baby and he's not
he's not at risk
i'm not saying there's no zero percent
risk but i'm following the science and
following the data
and this is this is part of the reason
that they haven't prioritized giving
kids the vaccine
kids are at very very very very very
very low risk
but when can my kid go outside and play
without the mask
kids can go outside and play without
masks
when they have reasonable parents that's
when that's going to be the determining
factor
when their parents are not so given over
to the neuroses
of this bizarre progressive scientific
culture
that they muzzle up their little kids
and don't let them play outside for a
year
that's when the kids will be able to go
outside and play absolutely pathetic
stuff
if you are not letting your kid go
outside and play cut it out
if you were forcing your little kid to
put the mask on all the time
cut it out cut it out come on man come
on man
come on be like corn pop corn pop
wouldn't have done that
someone wrote into the show yesterday
they said oh michael knowles are you you
still think that people
didn't need masks a year ago listen to
that language
i'm sure they're going to try to ding me
for this too but look at that word need
obviously we didn't need masks we could
have pursued some other policy other
places did pursue another policy
other many people in this country
pursued another policy by ignoring dr
fauci
like some people in this room perhaps
when you say we didn't need masks what
you're saying is
it was not advisable it was not this it
was not that
you didn't need masks is softening my
position which is a
political position not a scientific
position i'm saying as a political
matter
this was very harmful to society and
that was obviously correct
and it was it's correct today it was
correct a year ago and it's going to be
correct
tomorrow but because people are making
this category error we talked about this
a little bit last night on backstage
whereby the only way that we're able to
think
is through this very narrow scientific
material lens
then all of our ethical and
philosophical and political and
theological disagreements
have to be through that lens this is
accounts by the way
partially for the obsession with race
because race is a physical thing
so when we talk about evil when we talk
about
bigotry when we talk about redemption
when we talk about original sin
the only way we can talk about it is in
physical terms
white supremacy this color this
visual physical thing is the is the
stand-in now for evil
in the world that's a that's a problem
because in order to have self-government
we need to be able to talk about
metaphysical things we need to be able
to talk about good and bad and right and
wrong and true and false
and if you've lost the capacity to do
that
then you are going to lose your capacity
for self-government and you are going to
let this
freaking jerk dr fauci run your country
for a year or two years or three years
who knows how long this is going
to go speaking of the nature of our
political regime rudy giuliani
america's mayor one of the really great
mayors in the history of our country
greatest mayor in the history of new
york just got raided by the feds the
feds busted into his office and
department
this according to the washington post
the investigation into giuliani revolves
around his interactions with ukrainian
figures ahead of last year's
presidential election
as he sought information that might
prove politically damaging to
then-candidate joe biden
and pressed for the ouster of the u.s
ambassador to ukraine
cnn added he hasn't been charged
and has denied wrongdoing but but
america's mayor gets his office and
department busted into
because he was apparently digging up
dirt
on joe biden on behalf of donald trump
oh that's what it is that's what this is
a political persecution
got it you'll notice that prominent
democrats didn't get their offices
busted into
for digging up dirt in russia on donald
trump and they didn't even really dig up
dirt
they just hired this intelligence guy
they hired a bunch of spooks one of whom
was christopher steele
to create a totally uncorroborated
read fictional dossier on what donald
trump did in russia
we know that the democrats did what they
are accusing rudy giuliani of doing on
behalf of donald trump
we know that happened but they don't
face consequences
and giuliani apparently does he is at
least facing intimidation
he's at least facing the threat because
the american political regime is gay
oriented
to support the left and to
attack the right and to only apply
certain laws on the right and not on the
left and to criminalize
things that the left gets away with when
the right does it
which brings us to the political
commentator the right-wing commentator
nick fuentes
nick fuentes is this uh
quite right-wing young internet
commentator
who is apparently being persecuted by
the regime
now i say apparently or i say reportedly
because nick fuentes
says that he is on the no-fly list he
says that he went to go
on a flight to give a press conference
in florida
and and the lady at the gate check said
no you can't do that
and he said why is this an airline thing
is this a tsa thing
is this a federal government thing and
she said i can't give you any
information on that i can either confirm
or deny that you're on the list
but you are not permitted to fly
i say apparently and reportedly because
i've only ever met this guy once
and it was a dishonest interaction he
he was deceptive in his dealings with me
and i didn't know who he was
and so i don't know i don't know if his
account is trustworthy but
i'm going to go on the assumption that
it is because
skeptical as i am of this guy i'm very
very skeptical of the federal government
i'm seeing what they're doing to rudy
giuliani and i'm seeing what they've
done to donald trump and i'm seeing what
they do
to conservatives all the time
consider let's say the worst opinion you
could possibly have about this guy nick
fuentes
do you really think that
it is just that he is not permitted to
travel
he a guy who has not been accused of or
convicted of any crime to my knowledge
he should not be allowed to get on an
airplane but
patrice culler's the head of black lives
matter she is she's cool runs an
organization runs a
political movement that burned down the
country last year she's allowed to
travel wherever she wants
she gets flown around to travel all over
the place but
this guy nick fuentes is not because he
holds opinions
that are radical and that the regime
does not approve of
patrice cullers holds very radical
opinions that the regime does approve of
so she gets to do whatever she wants and
her movement burned down the country
doesn't matter
consider nicole hannah jones is that her
name yes
nicole hannah jones is the head of the
1619 project at the new york times
totally lied the whole the whole premise
of the pulitzer prize winning 6019
project
is the lie that the american revolution
was started
to preserve slavery
the political philosopher charles
kessler during the blm riots last year
he came out and he said i'm going to
start calling these the 1619 riots
because i think the 1619 project was
responsible for it do you know what
nicole hannah jones said she said i'm
proud of that oh great
please i'm honored that you would call
these riots the 6019 riots
claiming responsibility
bragging that she incited these riots
that woman is still allowed to get on an
airplane but nick fuentes is not
yeah but nick fuentes holds radical
opinions that i find very distasteful
yeah sure what about
nicole hannah jones she holds very
radical opinions
that i find very very distasteful and
she's claiming to have
incited these riots but she gets not
only does she get to fly
somebody tells me she gets flown around
all over the place
there is big money and big privilege for
radicalism
in favor of the liberal regime
and there would appear to be again i
don't know if it's true or not
tucker carlson the other night uh last
night or the night before mentioned this
story and he said the same thing we
haven't been able to verify this is true
but it would seem that the right gets
persecuted
and from what's going on with rudy
giuliani it would seem
that the right even a much much more
mainstream right wing figure
for a mayor of new york former lawyer
for the president gets persecuted
and it would seem you all know this
that the right-wingers in this country
play by a different set of rules
blm burns down the country they face
very few consequences
the horn guy jumps into the capital on
january 6th and dances around the desk
all those people are facing very very
serious consequences getting pinched by
feds
told that it's an insurrection the left
burns down the country that's a peaceful
protest
the right goes in and disrupts the
capital that's an insurrection
watching watching this speech last night
it was a very eerie feeling i've visited
washington dc
many times since january 6th dc
looks like a war zone it looks like one
of the places that the liberal regime
would occupy in the middle east
barbed wire up fencing up the military's
still there
national guard still occupying dc joe
biden giving this speech to a muzzled
audience
in a mostly empty room it
it made me wonder huh is that
what if this is if this is not the
insurrection what does the insurrection
look like
this is when i think of insurrection i
don't know when i think of a coup
it's it doesn't seem very very easily
distinguished from what
this is raises lots of questions
about the difference between how the
government is supposed to work on paper
and the way the government works in
practice i'm michael nolsas the michael
miller show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show joe biden unleashes an
interminable soporific address to
congress and puts america to sleep
while preaching insane radical leftism
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen
you